"Слуги народу" оплесками проводжають тепер уже колишнього міністра оборони Олексія Резнікова
після того, як проголосували за його відставку.
Уже наступного дня Рада призначає нового очільника міноборони.
Ним став Рустем Умєров, який до цього очолював Фонд держмайна.
Чому кадрові зміни відбуваються саме зараз?
І чого чекати від нового керівника оборонного відомства?
Олексій Резніков чимало зробив для забезпечення ЗСУ західним озброєнням.
Утім, як визнають експерти, у самому міністерстві назрівали проблеми.
Спершу - скандал із закупівлею продуктів для військових за завищеними цінами.
За пів року - ще один, так званий "курточний" скандал.
Ці скандали стали можливими якраз через те, що пан Резніков був сфокусований
в основному на міжнародну роботу, на міжнародні аспекти надання допомоги ЗСУ,
і сама внутрішня організація міністерства як системи, можливо,
була не до кінця контрольована і це зумовлювало можливості для цих скандалів.
За словами політолога Володимира Фесенка, заміну Олексію Резнікову не вдавалося знайти понад пів року.
Більшість кандидатів відмовлялися йти на цю посаду,
оскільки дуже велика увага зараз до цього міністерства.
Це, як хтось пожартував, як електричний стілець.
Тобто ти одразу потрапляєш під прожектори надмірної уваги, критику,
журналістські розслідування і так далі.
Не надто публічного Рустема Умєрова експерти називають ефективним менеджером і переговорником.
Він навчався на Заході, працював в інвестиційному бізнесі,
став народним депутатом від партії "Голос".
Після початку повномасштабного вторгнення був у складі української делегації на перемовинах з Росією,
а також займався адвокацією поставок західної зброї.
Умєров має достатньо досвіду в управлінні складними командами
як в управлінні державними органами, так і всередині бізнес-структур як в Україні, так і за кордоном.
Він також розуміється на збройних питаннях, входив до складу тимчасової слідчої комісії,
яка стежила за тим, куди йде міжнародна збройна допомога.
Тобто це людина не з вулиці, вона розуміється на питаннях оборони й безпеки.
Крім того, Рустем Умєров - етнічний кримський татарин і мусульманин.
Міжнародні ЗМІ зазначають: його призначення може бути сигналом
про те, що Україна не поступиться Кримом.
Його турецькі зв'язки кажуть, що він має прямий доступ до офісу Ердогана
і навіть один з небагатьох українських керівників, який має можливість напряму спілкуватися з Ердоганом.
Це обумовило його участь у переговорах в березні торік,
але також в переговорах по зерновій угоді,
в переговорах про обмін полоненими, зокрема, по обміну "азовців".
Наведення ладу з контрактами на зброю й у системі закупівель,
боротьба зі зловживаннями, цифровізація армії,
належне забезпечення війська - те, чого очікують від нового міністра оборони.
Що мені здається важливо було б для нового міністра
- це добитися синергії в роботі трьох міністерств:
це міністерство оборони, стратегічної промисловості і цифрової трансформації.
Тут має бути синергія, більше має бути лідерства і, як мені здається,
лідерства саме міністерства оборони.
За рік роботи на посаді очільника Фонду держмайна пан Умєров уникнув скандалів, конфліктів.
Якщо він навів лад у достатньо проблемній структурі як Фонд держмайна,
то можливо він зможе навести лад і в міноборони.
Це буде його головна місія.
Очільниця Центру протидії корупції Дар'я Каленюк звертає увагу на необхідність
масштабних кадрових чисток у міноборони.
А також на те, що новому очільнику відомства варто довести свою незалежність
від керівника Офісу президента Андрія Єрмака, адже такі закиди на його адресу вже є.
Я буду судити наскільки Умєров є людиною Єрмака
за його кадровими призначеннями, а особливо за його рішеннями
стосовно заступника міністра оборони Шарапова. Шарапов - це ексбізнеспартнер Єрмака,
який зараз координує всі оборонні закупівлі, збройні і незбройні,
і несе відповідальність за провал цих закупівель разом з міністром Резніковим.
Тому побачимо наскільки навіть за бажання Умєрова
звільнити таку одіозну постать як Шарапов
йому це дозволить президент та наш де-факто "віцепрезидент" Андрій Єрмак.
Міністерство оборони є найбільшим розпорядником коштів в Україні, поки триває війна.
Тож увага до цього відомства залишатиметься надзвичайно прискіпливою.